well they got dumped out of the europa
league by dinamo zagreb this season
quite humiliating for them and
ultimately now jose mourinho
has lost his job yeah that was
interesting ended that we had that news
about mourinho this morning do we have
any idea if it's related to this super
league news
so two schools of thought there are
reports this morning that there was
uh an explosive rouse that's being
described on social media
mourinho refusing to take the players
out to train
in response to tottenham signing up to
this european
super league no confirmation of that
whatsoever from the club in their
statement
they say quite simply that he was a true
professional
those are the words of daniel levy
tottenham's chairman
who also paid tribute to mourinho's
resilience during the pandemic but
whatever has happened he is gone you
could see this is a good day to bury bad
news really because in the football
world
everyone focusing on this proposed new
european super league but let's be
honest mourinho's football here
over the past few weeks and months has
not been what tottenham hotspur fans
have wanted
they reached the champions league final
in may 2019 under the previous manager
maurizio pochettino
playing a far more attractive brand of
football a lot of people were unhappy to
see him leave the club
and mourinho leaves tottenham now with
the club in seventh
crashing out of europe to dinamar zagreb
and they've got a cup final this coming
weekend sunday
afternoon at wembley against manchester
city far
far from ideal preparation